bonjour thibault merci merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france je lisais
entrée en vigueur aujourd'hui du pass
sanitaire à l'échelle européenne
quel oeil voiliers de quelle il volleye
vous justement ce procédé
je vais vous le dire hier je lisais dans
la presse que c'est un cadeau que
l'europe fait appeler ses concitoyens
mais je pense plutôt que c'est un cadeau
empoisonné que l'europe fait à ses
concitoyens je m'explique on nous dit
que la philosophie de ce pass sanitaire
européen est simple c'est celle de
retrouver la liberté
alors on nous met une petite barrière et
maintenant on nous donne une clé pour
pouvoir l'ouvrir mais en fait ce pass
sanitaire ce n'est absolument pas la
liberté au contraire je pense qu'on met
le doigt dans un engrenage qui nous
emmène vers quelque chose qui est à
l'opposé de nos traditions de liberté en
europe puisque désormais avec se passe
on laisse à un état ou une autorité
publique politiques la possibilité de
décider sur quels critères vous aurez le
droit d'accéder à la vie en société ou
le droit de voyager et maintenant
finalement vous n'aurez le droit de
voyager que lorsqu'on aura éradiquer ce
qu'il y a 2 potentiellement dangereux en
vous aujourd'hui c'est le co vie de 19
et demain qu'est ce que ça sera une
maladie mentale la production d'un
casier vierge
je vous rappelle que l'on donné à ce
passeport européen par l'union
européenne ce n'est pas un passeport
passeport sanitaire c'est un certificat
vert numérique qu'est ce qu'on met
dedans maintenant une attestation que
nous sommes pas contaminés par le copil
19 et demain et c'est là où ça me paraît
quelque chose de très dangereux
d'un point de vue juridique avec les
lois européennes est ce que
ce pass sanitaire est quelque chose de
légal tout simplement
ces deux là confié delà de la compétence
de l'union européenne que de régler les
transports et le passage des frontières
en son sein donc évidemment c'est tout à
fait légal
après est ce que c'est pour autant
légitime de restreindre la circulation
de la population européenne
dans de telles proportions pour un virus
donc il faut vraiment le rappeler encore
une fois qui n'est pas la peste et qui
finalement a plus entraîné une crise
logistique que sanitaire on le sait de
nombreux foyers de contamination ont été
détectés récemment notamment à cause des
délais grands déplacements des
supporters de football lors de l'euro si
on ne met pas en place se passe
sanitaire qu'est ce qu'on peut mettre en
place à côté
écoutez actuellement je pense que
jusqu'à hier il fallait produire un test
pcr pour traverser les frontières
ce qui finalement sera à peu près
exactement la même chose maintenant à la
différence que l'on pourra aussi
maintenant montrer qu'on est vaccinée
les autorités sanitaires de ce pays nous
disent d'ailleurs que le vaccin ne
suffit pas à noeux pour ne pas
transmettre le virus dont peut-être que
même resté tout simplement à la
production d'un test pcr aurait été plus
efficace puisque là au moins on est sûr
que nous ne sommes pas contaminés quoi
qu'il en soit au delà de de ces gadgets
technologiques c'est aussi une
philosophie une vision du monde que nous
voulons avoir
est-ce que nous allons prenez un monde
du zéro virus du zéro qu'ovide 19 alors
que des virus il y en aura toujours il y
en a toujours eu il faut plutôt à mon
avis revenir à une idée très simple que
l'homme est mortel et que et que le coc
vide peut tuer mais peut très très peu
tué finalement est ce qu'on est sûr
aussi également
que tous les pays les 33 pays concernés
un parent se passe sanitaires vont
respecter scrupuleusement les consignes
est liée à ce passe sanitaires alors
c'est la 1ère un point très important a
noté se passe sanitaire n'empêchera pas
les pays de fixer eux mêmes des règles
pour l'entrée ou la sortie de leur
territoire ce qui veut dire que
concrètement demain vous voulez partir
en grèce et la grèce des sites que vous
serez soumis à une quarantaine si vous
venez dans un pays où il ya par exemple
ce variant indien la grèce pourra le
faire et l'europe ne pourra pas
l'empêcher donc finalement ce passeport
vert est un est un gadget qui
n'empêchera absolument pas là la
restriction de circulation cet été
d'ailleurs est-ce que aussi
l'instauration de ce pass sanitaire ne
serait pas justement aussi le moyen
d'inciter peut-être les européens se
faire vacciner tout à fait ça ça m'a
tout l'air d'être de créer une
obligation vaccinale indirects
d'ailleurs on a appelé au début ce
passeport vaccinale alors qu'il faut
rappeler que c'est un passeport
sanitaire nous vous pouvez produire un
pcr ou une preuve de contamination et
même dans certains pays un test
antigénique suffira mais c'est vrai
qu'on peut on voit bien que la stratégie
à l'une au niveau européen et au niveau
français c'est de prôner la vaccination
comme unique possibilité de sortie de
cette crise sanitaire
merci beaucoup thibault mercier d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin sur arte france
rappelle que vous êtes avocat au barreau
de paris et président du cercle à droits
et libertés merci beaucoup